hi I'm next gasps ladies and gentlemen
is the comedian whose debut comedy album
9.2 on pitchfork is available now it's
actually a coincidence that Ron Funches
in here on the same show because Ron
used to sleep on his couch is that true
run yeah you sleep on his couch we used
to hang out and just this was a dream of
ours to be here together so I'm happy to
see him I know he's about to kill it
yeah okay please welcome back to the
show the very funny Ian Karmel
[Music]
[Applause]
what just went here can you believe it I
can we used to I guess it is fairly
believable but we used to remember we
used to smoke pot and then talk about
how one day maybe we could be on Conan
together yeah that was yesterday yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
happens fairly often but now that this
has come true maybe the other thing we
used to talk about could come true too
maybe we're both going to be invited
into the wu-tang clan I think it's gonna
happen
RZA the balls in your court
my name is going to be a vegetable
sitcom
very optimistic it is wonderful it is
wonderful to be here I I'm from Portland
Oregon originally that's not actually
true I'm originally from from Beaverton
Oregon a place called Beaverton Oregon
Yeah right yeah for those of you don't
know Beaverton Oregon is one of the
widest places on the planet Earth it is
in credit like the blackest kid at my
high school it was this Korean dude who
could breakdance a little bit like a
little he wasn't even good at it but he
had a wu-tang clan t-shirt so we were
all on board we're all like it's you
you're the basketball team now I live
here in LA which is wonderful Los
Angeles is very diverse it's incredibly
diverse here even the neighborhood names
in LA are diverse right you're like
driving around and it's like little
Armenia little Bangladesh Thai town
Chinatown Little Tokyo all of which are
amazing Mexican American community
[Applause]
I miss Portland I miss Portland Oregon a
lot which is probably why I keep dating
women who still live in Portland Oregon
which is a mistake because that means
I'm in a lot of long-distance
relationships and when you're in a
long-distance relationship that means
you have to have phone sex which is
terrible for me because I do not have a
good phone sex voice at all like my last
girlfriend had a beautiful sexy voice it
was wonderful to listen to her talk
about anything my voice isn't beautiful
or sexy at all my voice sounds like of a
trumpet could be Jewish that's they call
me the Jewish trumpet that's my other
whoo tang man the Jews but I mean like
you know what can you imagine having
phone sex and this is the voice on the
other side of the line just like I'm
inside of you right now bubble
you could always the miss you be wise
one of my best friends still like it
they do think that's awful fiddler on
the roof again and I did hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography